[Music]
sorry
Oh God that's disgusting Oh what have
you had a cold am i next during flu cold
season you might notice a lot of
sneezing going on viruses like those
that cause colds and influenza rely on
sneezes as a sneaky way to spread they
hide in mucus droplets that can end up
on the surfaces that you touch or even
directly on you if you happen to get in
the way as a spray so how far away do
you have to stand to make sure you stay
safe time to science
[Music]
sometimes when you sneeze a fine spray
comes out other times big ol stick
boogers come flopping out these thicker
boogers have a higher viscosity a
measure of how thick and viscous the
fluid is both sick and since measles can
spread germs but how does the viscosity
of a sneeze affect how far it spreads to
find out we need to do an experiment
first we need a hypothesis or a
prediction that we can test this
prediction we'll compare a variable
something that changes against a control
or something that stays the same in our
case we want to compare thick versus
thin nasal goo my hypothesis is that
thick viscous slime will spatter less
and go less far than Vince not well but
how are we going to test this No -
sneezes are alike after all in this case
we can actually simplify this down we're
going to create a model a representation
of something that happens in the real
world we're going to use this little
dropper as our artificial nose we'll
fill it with our fake snot and squeeze
the bulb to make the snot fly to measure
just how far it goes we'll squeeze this
bulb and position it over a long tarp
which I've marked out in centimeters and
meters to show just how far our snot
rockets fly for our thick fluid I found
a recipe using corn syrup and gelatin it
creates this nice gross goopy mess
snot is actually a mixture of water with
sugars and proteins so corn syrup and
gelatin are a pretty good stand-in for
thin snot I'm just using colored water
for each type of snot we load up our
dropper smack the bulb and watch the
fluid fly then we measure how far it
went we can also divide up our tarp into
sections to find out where the fluid
concentrates for each kind of snot this
will allow us to create a graph called a
histogram but hold on a second we just
did that one that's not enough if we
want to learn about sneezes in general
we need to run this a lot more times how
many times I need to do something called
a power analysis the not behind this can
get a little complicated but I've used
this handy table it tells me that in
order to compare the differences between
my two types of snot I need to run each
kind 26-time
better get to it whoo now we've got all
our data and it's time to group it
together to find the mean or the average
for the six knot and the thinnest not to
find out how far they flew then we'll
run a test called a t-test this is a
statistical test that we can use to
determine if the distance that the fix
knot and the fence not flew was
different enough to mean anything
my t-test shows that yes these are
different my viscous knot also
concentrated much closer to the sneezer
than my fins not dead and my effect
sizes show that these differences are
very large indeed when conducting
scientific experiments it's important to
compare results have other scientists
studied snot what did they get well a
2016 study showed that larger snot
droplets spray an average of two meters
while smaller ones can spray up to eight
meters or 26 feet a 2005 study also
showed that increasing the cohesion of
mucus droplets making them stick
together and glop more actually decrease
the distance that the mucus could travel
and made it less easy to hit a target
how did ours compare well our mucus
didn't fly quite as well as the 2016
study but that could be because our tiny
dropper isn't a good substitute for a
nose and squeezing the bulb isn't
exactly a strong achoo but we did show
that changing the viscosity of our fluid
decreased the distance that it could go
like the 2005 study keep in mind that
most sneezes are a mixture of Finn's
knot and six knots so stand well back
regardless and the best way to stop a
sneezes spread is to cut it off at the
source
so sneezers cover your nose enough and
wash your hands
anything else is not cool
do you have any experiments you want me
to try leave your ideas in the comments
and don't forget to subscribe for more
awesome experimental videos and if you
want to perform this experiment yourself
head over to your Riga lab where you can
find the full description of how to
perform the experiment and all the
analyses the links are right down below
and thank you so much to Matt Harding's
an American University for lending us
this awesome lab space
[Music]